الكوكب المكتشف حديثا والذي اعلنت عنه
الجمعيه الفلكيه الامريكيه في سياكل هو
كوكب صخري يساوي حجمه 95% من حجم كوكب
الارض وذلك باستخدام التلسكوب جيمس ويب
الفضائي التابعي لناسا ويكمل مدارا حول
شمس في غضون يومين فقط
وفكرت ناسا ان هذا الكوكب يقع على مسافه
من نجمه التي يدور حوله وهو ما يسمح بوجود
الماء على سطحه وما يجعل من المحتمل ان
يكون قابلا للعيش او يحتوي على مظاهر
للحياه
حسب وكاله ناسا فان الكوكب الجديد شديد
الحراره وهو اكثر سخونه من كوكب الارض بضع
مئات من درجات الحراره يقود فريق البحث
كيفن ستيفن سنن
وجاكولسيجر وكلاهما من مختبر الفيزياء
التطبيقيه لجام
فلسطين
هذا الكوكب الخارجي بحجم الارض وتاكيده ثم
ان عمق الكوكب وكميه الضوء المحجوبه
اعطينا مقياسا لنصف قطر كوكب والذي اتضح
انه مماثل تماما لنصف قطع الارض
على الرغم من ان البيانات تظهر ان هذا
كوكب بحجم الارض تقريبا فان الباحثين لا
يعرفون حتى الان ما اذا كان له غلاف جوي
وان كان لا يستبعدونه وجود بعض تركيبات
الجويه قرب الكوكب كما ان نتائج الباحثين
فتحت امامهم امكانيات تحديد الكواكب بحجم
الارض التي تدور حول النجوم المتناهيه
الصغار هذه النتائج تفتح الباب امام
العديد من الاحتمالات المستقبليه وتثير
شهيه العلماء بشان مدى وجود حيوات اخرى
على سطح كواكب مجهوله بالنسبه الينا نحن
سكان كوكب الارض